we know that ashara dayne dance the net
we know that she was a sir bursts and
calls the dishonored by a stark at
Harrenhal we know that a char gave birth
to daughter and we know that Danny
resembles a char a lot
[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like from the very beginning of the game
of Thrones you've been told that John is
a bastard son of Ned Stark while the
nurses true born Targaryen daughter of
the Mad King later in the show we've
learned that John is in fact the true
burnt a Gary Ennis his legitimate son of
lien and Rhaegar Targaryen not only
fulfilled his promise to his dying
sister by passing John as his bastard
son in order to protect him from his
friend Robert Baratheon who would have
had John killed if he'd ever found out
the true lineage of Jon Snow with a
story being revealed is there anything
left well according to some fans the
final twist of the show will be Dany in
fact being Ned's bastard daughter John
being the son of Leah and Rhaegar might
have come as a huge twist and surprise
to some of you but the fact is that
there was plenty of hints and clues
pointing on Jonah being Ned's bastard
but we're a legitimate son of lien and
Rhaegar unlike most of other TV shows
Game of Thrones is show that his many
times were shadowed many events far in
advance that's mostly because the
showrunners have a show based on a book
series and the show is not written in
season by season basis let me just put
it this way by the time they started
writing the first episode of the very
first season they had already known
about all main events and twists that
would happen in the entire show
so they decided foreshadow most of them
in the season 5 maester aemon while
having a conversation with Sam about the
nearest four share of jobs real
parentage Amon did not make claim or any
suggestion of Jon being more than
bastard but the scene self gave us a
huge hint as I was saying while having
conversation with Sam about the
narasimham said a Targaryen alone in the
world is a terrible thing the camera
cuts back to Sam listening and as soon
as Amon finishes his sentence John walks
in at a time most of us didn't even
notice this detail while some thought
it's just coincidence only to find out
in the season 6 finale that Justin is in
fact a Targaryen
Joshua lineage has been hinted many
times through the show in season 5
Johnson was elected Lord Commander while
at the same time Stannis and his wife
were staying at Castle black
at one point Sally status tan is dead
John is only a bastard by some tavern
woman that was promiscuous on it
Standish replied with perhaps but that
wasn't Ned Stark's way pointing out that
Ned Stark was too honorable to do such
thing
long story short there was plenty of
hints and clues they were pointing on
Jana being as bastard but do we have the
same amount of clues and hints for Danny
being Ned's bastard daughter yes in fact
there's much more closing hints backing
up this theory
lien and Rhaegar fell in love at a great
tourney at Harrenhal and according to
this theory in according to main
characters in the book series they were
not the only ones
Ned Stark in a sharda indeed - and it
salted at the birth of the nears oh so
let me just remind you that during this
earning Ned Stark wasn't pledged to
anyone it was his older brother Brandon
that was committed to Catelyn Tully
anyways before I get into all the hints
and clues let me tell you a bit about a
Shar Annette s'posed lover lady ashara
dayne was a lady of house Dayne and
sister of Sir Arthur Dayne the sordid
morning she was stolen had long hair and
violet eyes azshara was an object of
infatuation for many men including
sandbar stand sell me at Stark Ned Stark
meta Shara the great tourney at
Harrenhal where they shared the
less-dense of the celebration and many
characters seem to believe those two
fell in love according to an entire day
in family ishara Ned Stark truly did
fall in love at her home lady alaria
Dana chars younger sister believed this
Lord a jig gain also known as Ned the
current Lord of star fool ishara
al-arian sir Arthur's nephew also
believed this in Storm of Swords little
sorry about his family about how his
aunt Azshara committed suicide over her
broken heart he the hesitantly tells
Arya that his aunt alaria told him that
a char and Eddard fell in love the
tourney at Harrenhal
Adric is surprised that letter never
spoke of her so she our sister and
nephew believed that she and Ned fell in
love with attorney sadly then the
rebellion broke and had suddenly found
himself to be the new Lord of Winterfell
during the time of war overwhelmed with
such responsibilities he immersed
himself in duty and honour and gets
engaged with Catelyn Tully after his
brother the one that had been committed
to Catelyn died following the showdown
at the tavern joy Eddard Stark travelled
to star fall to inform house Dayne of
Sir Arthur's death and to return his
sword on a shark committed suicide by
throwing herself on the top of the
tallest tower his star fallen to the
cliff at of the sea
Asher was suspected to be the matter of
Jon Snow and that her suicide was caused
by the grief over the hand her alleged
lover Eddard played in her brother's
death in the books Catelyn Stark even
asked him if this rumor was true and
that their dang girl told her to never
ask him about Jon that the ball was his
blood and that this was all she needed
to know quote that would not speak of
the matter not so much as a word but the
castle has no secrets and Catelyn hears
her maids repeating tales they heard
from the lips of her husband soldiers
they whispered of Sir Arthur Dayne the
sword of the morning the list of the
seven nights of Aerys Kingsguard and of
how their young Lord had slain him in
single combat and they told how
afterward Ned had carried Sir Arthur's
sword back to the beautiful young sister
who evaded him in a castle called starve
on the shores of the summer sea the lady
ashara dayne tall and fair with haunting
while a tie
it had taken her fortnight to marshal
her courage but finally in bed one night
Kathlyn had asked her husband the truth
of it there was the only time in all
their years that net had ever frightened
her never ask me about John his set
called his ice he is my blood and that
is all you need to know and now I will
learn very heard that name my lady
she had pledged you pay she told him and
from that day on the whispering had
stopped and the Sharda his name was
never heard in Winterfell again this
could explain why vennett recalls the
prices he paid dearly to keep his
promise to Liana a chars life could have
been that prized the woman he loved if
net he told the truth explained John
wasn't his bastard and her brother died
defending the heir to the Iron Throne
perhaps she wouldn't have committed
suicide but net had to keep his promise
that blames himself for chars death
because he had to keep the truth hidden
about Jon Snow as well as why he had to
kill her today the fact that he had to
keep his vows was his curse and that
resulted with a sharp suicide and that
guilt is the reason that for beta shards
name ever to be spoken in Winterfell
again as I already said after the
tourney at Harrenhal the two haven't
seen each other up until Ned Stark wrote
Starfall to deliver don't water sister
shardene
however net in this theory then found
out that there her whole story resulted
the child but both of them knew they
couldn't be together
by the time net source sure again he was
married had sister Santa passes his own
bastard then he had killed her brother
all of this combined till the end to
their relationship leading a shara to
commit suicide over her broken heart at
her broker chars heart and he knew it
again from arias conversation with Ed
shifting why did she jump in the sea
though she asked her heart was broken at
York answered did someone break it or I
asked he hesitated perhaps it's not my
place tell me are you insisted he looked
at her and comfortably and said my aunt
alaria says lady ishara and your father
fell in love with her hole but let's get
a bit back let's see how other
characters beside the Danes saw the
relationship between azshara in its
start here's the conversation between
Cersei Lannister Ned how dare you play
the noble Lord with me what they take me
for you're a bastard on your own I've
seen him who was the matter I wonder
some Dornish peasant you raved well her
whole face burned a [ __ ] or was it the
grieving sister the lady a shark she
threw herself into the sea untold why
was that for the brother is slow or the
child is tall Cersei Lannister twittered
Stark
despite this rumor services only believe
that a shark had given birth to a
stillborn daughter rather
to a son but was the daughter Julia
stillborn according to this theory no
Asha is neither matter of chance no nor
was her baby is stillborn the daughter
is in fact the nares herself the theory
goes that net conceived Danny with
ishara the great tourney at Harrenhal
let's say sir Barton's take on the
events at the tourney in the dance to
drag on stir bar since someone remembers
the greater need here hole I'm quoting
even after all these years serve arson
could still recall a sharp smile the
sound of her laughter he had only to
close his eyes to see her with her long
haired tumbling about her shoulders and
those haunting purple eyes Lanier says
the same eyes sometimes when the Queen
looked at him he felt as he were looking
at the chars daughter but a chars
daughter had been stillborn and his fair
lady had thrown herself from a tower
soon after met with grief for the shell
she had lost and perhaps for the man who
had dishonored her at Harrenhal as well
she died never knowing that sir burst
and had loved her
how could she he was a knight of the
Kingsguard sworn to celibacy no good
could have come from telling her his
feelings no good came from silence as
well if I had a horse Rhaegar and Crown
- our queen of love and beauty why she
have looked at me instead of stark
Merson says she was honoured by a stark
but his version is biased due to the
feelings he had for her but carving
gives us more neutral take when talking
to Arya Harvin is a member of the
household guard of Lord Eddard Stark at
Winterfell and he did give us a better
insight regarding the relationship
between knit in the Shara lady ashara
dayne
it's an old tale that one I heard it was
some interval when I was an older than
your now I doubt there's any truth to it
but if there is what of it
when that met this Dornish lady assure
his brother brandon was still alive and
it was him engaged to lady Catelyn so
there's no stain on your father's honour
there's no like attorney to make the
blunt run hot so maybe some words were
whispered in the tent of a knight who
can say words or kisses maybe more but
where's the harm in that
spring had come or so they thought and
neither of them was pledged harming -
Arya Stark before I provide you more
hints and clothes let me give you an
answer a question that most we probably
have at this point
the nurses daughter azshara gave birth
to and if Ned Stark's release her father
how does she look like a Targaryen well
the truth is that they ensure the same
features as a Targaryen the Danes hair
has been described as pale blond dark
and silver Danes have been observed with
black blue or purple eyes beside this
fact REM chap during a feast or grouse
also confirmed that house Dane does
produce children that have the classical
valerie feature
silver hair purple eyes so then having
this popularly called Targaryen features
does not mean she's necessarily a
Targaryen and she could also be a Dane
and have these features so if then his
nets and a shark child she inherited her
traits from her mother azshara then even
look so Targaryen that she could be
passed as one
don't forget sir person's thoughts in
books while remembering what ashara
dayne looked like he remarks that
Daenerys resembles her shang the same
violet eyes as her he claims that when
Danny looked at him he felt that he was
looking at the Sharpe's opposed or
quoting the nurses the same eyes
sometimes when the Queen looked at him
he felt as if he were looking at a chars
daughter then a nurse doesn't he violet
eyes in the show as she does in the
novel's but it doesn't mean that this
theory couldn't come true in the show as
well since the show did try it
Emily a cleric aka the nearest wore
purple contact lenses Finnish show
started but they were uncomfortable and
negatively affected her performance so
they were abandoned let's not take a
look on Denny's memories and see if we
can find any clues there as well we have
Dane his memories of serval and dari a
night of house dairy who remained loyal
to House Targaryen during and after
Robert's rebellion and the men who
smuggled viserys and danerys across the
Narrow Sea quoting he called her little
princess and sometimes my lady my lady
is not an appropriate thing to call a
princess it is however a fitting title
for the daughter of a char Dane the
dairy occasional let's leave what he
knew the next clue we find when they no
flex reserve seeming erratic attitude
quoting for centuries the Targaryens had
married brother to sister since Aegon
the Conqueror had taken his sister to
bride the line must be kept pure wizard
she told her a thousand times theirs was
the king's but the golden blood of old
Valyria the blood of the dragon dragons
did not mate with the beasts of the
field and Targaryen did not mingle their
blood with that of lesser man it now is
their scheme to sell her to a stranger a
barbarian now let's see if george RR
martin the creator of this fiction
universe author of epic fantasy novels
so Song of Ice and Fire which was later
adapted into the HBO series Game of
Thrones gives us any clue regarding this
theory the danes are still going to play
an important role in the future george
RR martin stated this leads us to
another George RR Martin's confirmation
regarding the dates you'll see more
Danes in future books that's all I can
say this could determine that we will
learn more the Danes that are alert
introduced in story or we will see more
new characters could be that there are
Danes that we already know of but are
not aware of them being paints the last
big twist might be Danish troll in each
way too much was made of net attraction
toward sharp
and sir burster marking how much Danny
resembles her this whole time had been
expecting from John to find something in
the crypts of interval and finally
learned the truth about his lineage the
truth is however the John will most
likely learning from his best friends
salmon bran crits might still hold a
great importance for story as it might
be holding the truth about other main
characters parentage then he is on her
way to Winterfell and we didn't even
think that it could be her in fact that
he'll find something in the crypts and
learned the shocking truth about her
lineage what's also point out the fact
that george RR martin confirmed himself
George has worked out a whole family
tree for house Dayne and it will be
published in the future books
this means that something huge is coming
as only the Great Houses get family
trees worked out the fact that George
Armand is waiting for the right time to
publish this one means that it will
likely be a huge twist regarding the
Dayne family could Ned Stark and
Daenerys be placed in this family tree
we know that a shard ends with Ned we
know that she was a server stand calls a
dishonored by a stark at Harrenhal
we know that the Shire gave birth to a
daughter and we know the Daniel
resembles azshara locked and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]